part of it is money right like resources
like i
i've been like a skinny asian kid my
whole life until
i realized
my first paycheck where i was like i can
get a steak and the app
and the dessert and a drink you know
because i didn't grow up like that it
was just like yeah we didn't first of
all we didn't go out and if you did
you're not getting are you
is there like is it official you are the
wealthiest painter alive
um
yes
i gotta ask my question then what what
was the first thing you did with your
first big paycheck
what would you buy a steak and an
appetizer just a steak
this is this is the
the
it's it's not um
a sexy answer but i think
this is um
must be nice
must be nice to be rich right it must be
nice to have your own sprinter van like
oh if i if i had you know all the haters
and like oh if i had your money i would
do you know and i and i go
i do the same [ __ ]
when i was po you know like right it's
like
you you've done you get this right
you're like must be nice to be jackass
four in a multi-million and you're like
wait like i was doing stunts when i had
nothing with grocery carts
so
it's a weird thing to say to someone
like
i hitchhiked all over the world before i
had a dime i begged for rides i begged
to stay at people's houses i was a world
traveler with no money right i've
paint i used to steal spray paint and
just paint like
food that i couldn't afford i would
shoplift so like i'm not i'm not you
know saying you should do this but i
just i did whatever i wanted right so
when the money hit the bank account
um not that it's not important it just
was like whatever you know and then i
did all the pitfalls i bought all the
cars i bought all the [ __ ] and i was
like
i don't need any of this stuff like my
life is very simple right like yeah and
uh it's like i don't have that much
stuff now like i'm trying to go more
minimal and almost all my resources and
time is to just like helping people and
and doing that but
um you know the headlines is like
richest artists in the world and and to
be honest like when i met mark
zuckerberg and sean parker i didn't
believe in their company and you know
i've talked about all this stuff and i
wasn't on social media and i probably
still wouldn't be on i mean i'm on
social i have a social media presence
but it's not me like my social you know
i know this is all douchey [ __ ] my
social media team does that you know and
so
um
yeah i i was like facebook myspace i
don't like what i have friends like i
don't need this [ __ ] it seems so
stupid so
when facebook started taking over
myspace because you remember how
gigantic that was
i wasn't even paying attention
so like
like my whole life is gambling so i have
all these things that i would bet on and
some of them paid off and some of them
didn't and that was one that was paying
off but i wasn't even paying attention
to it
because my art career was taking off my
paintings were selling for like more
money than i you know but i wasn't like
as well known and the gambling was
taking off i mean i wasn't winning
i i figured i i kind of don't like
talking about it because
you don't want to encourage [ __ ] yeah i
don't yeah because it's it
um
people hit you up all the time about how
to be like stevo or jack at you know all
that kind of [ __ ] and it's
and and it's
this is what i would say
because because my teacher caught me
when my art teacher caught me once
giving advice after i caught up and he's
like you know the advice you give is
very dangerous because you're giving it
to like normal people who aren't like
you and i think you and i
are
i know this sounds very like
braggadocious but i think we're really
good
at making it look like we're just having
a good time and [ __ ] around and
making it look easy and just acting
stupid and crazy
and it doesn't account for the years
the years of discipline and all the
boring [ __ ] that we don't show right
like
like oh look at that guy's just throwing
paint i'm like bro do you know what i do
after the camera's off i just ch chin
like
the clown school you went to the stun
like all this [ __ ] practice and then
when the camera's on you just do it and
you're like oh he's just [ __ ] around
so
you know
yeah so people
it's it's more fun it's more fun for me
when i read the headlines even like it's
when i go watch the
social network
movie by david fincher it's like it's
like i liked that it's [ __ ] awesome
but it's just not true every time
i was there for all of it i'm like wow
that is like the most
exaggerated like intense like hollywood
made-up version and it was just not that
you know yeah sure this
it happens is there a documentary
version of it that that's actually
accurate
i'm trying to think maybe the
documentary version would be even more
crazy
every time i think about mark zuckerberg
i think about the actor that played him
yeah
and like and i'm friends with sean
parker and then when i think about hey
like justin john parker is the napster
guy yeah right justin timberlake yeah
you know a million dollars you know
what's cool a billion dollars
how about just
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and sky
jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
[Applause]